they're not comic book heroes
but each of these predators has
abilities that defy the imagination
faster than a speeding bullet
armed with x-ray vision they're hypnotic
they're transformers
and they can smell their prey from two
miles away
they're the world's deadliest animals
and they've got super powers
the world's top predators
are experts on the hunt
[Applause]
but some take life into the realm of the
fantastic
more than hunters
they are dazzlers
more than stalkers
they are miracle workers
they have super speed super sight sixth
senses
and like the grizzly bear
a super sense of smell
the grizzly bear is widely known as one
of the most massive
and ferocious predators in the natural
world
it may also have one of the most
powerful senses of smell on earth
[Music]
the scent detecting area of a grizzly's
nose is 100 times larger than a human's
and it bristles with over a billion
receptor cells connected to over 10
million nerve cells sending
scent-powered shock waves to the brain
it is believed that these bears can
smell other bears
trash
or even a rotting animal's carcass in
the lean days of winter from more than a
mile away
it's that super-powered nose that keeps
the grizzly bear alive when a good meal
is just a bit harder to come by
elk are an occasional meal
with young ones just after birth odors
can be particularly strong
[Music]
[Music]
it's just a matter of time before the
young elk slips up
so
the chase yields an important meal for
this grizzly bear family
something that can be even harder to
come by in the leanest days of the
grizzly bear life cycle
thanks to one of the strongest noses on
the planet
but even the strongest nose on earth
can't smell certain things that this
snake can smell
because the snake's super smell uses two
different high-powered organs together
this snake has nostrils on top of its
head
plus an extra feature called the
jacobson's organ
this organ is a sensor and it allows
snakes to detect chemicals in its
surroundings that could lead it to prey
enhanced smell for the hunt
when this snake
and this snake
and this snake
snap their tongues
they're collecting chemical information
about their environment that can't be
detected through an ordinary nose
pheromones for example are chemicals
that allow animals to send signals to
one another
a bee will release pheromones to attract
other bees
this mouse's pheromones will influence
the behavior of other mice
and with the help of the jacobson's
organ this python can sense their
pheromones
first the snake's tongue flips in the
air
when it retracts its tongue
the snake inserts the fork tip inside
its head into the jacobson's organ which
allows the snake to detect the mouse
pheromones providing extra information
to use to track its prey
[Music]
nose
tongue and jacobson's organ work
together
and in an instant the hunter prevails
thanks to a tongue that can smell
but perhaps the most impressive nose in
the animal kingdom
is also the most fantastic because of
what surrounds it
the owner lives below ground in a world
of perpetual darkness
surrounded by the crawling creatures on
which it prays
down here eyes and ears are meaningless
and touch is everything
[Music]
this is the realm of the star-nosed mole
it gets its name from the 22 appendages
or feelers that surround its nose
each feeler is covered with thousands of
sensory receptors called imers organs
that make the star one of the most
ultra-sensitive organs of any in the
animal kingdom
it's so sensitive it can detect minute
particles like a grain of salt buried in
a pile of sand
[Applause]
the mole lives on worms insects and
small fish
the outer tentacles probe for a
potential meal
then the inner sensors determine if the
prey is edible
[Music]
the mole is practically blind
to better see it presses its feelers to
the ground
[Music]
which transmits a three-dimensional
picture of the terrain back to its brain
like a mental sonogram
and when it presses down its feelers
it does it at warp speed
[Applause]
[Music]
one of its favorite meals
earthworms
[Music]
for the star-nosed mole the worms
tell-tale segments and hooks are a dead
giveaway
[Music]
but to find it the mole has to touch it
it's amazing ultra sensitive feelers
have rewarded it with yet another meal
to be enjoyed in the darkness of its
creepy super powered world
[Music]
back in the daylight super powered
vision
helps the crafty kestrel scan for prey
in an instant
it strikes with precision
[Music]
the kestrel is a finely tuned killer
successful enough that their territory
has spread nearly across the globe
the most spectacular weapon in its
arsenal
are super-powered eyes
capable of seeing far beyond the range
of human beings
capable of seeing
in ultraviolet light
[Music]
it's prey the vole spends much of its
time underground or beneath dense
vegetation
but when the vole moves it marks
territory and pathways with urine
the markings are invisible even to the
vole
but they are visible in ultraviolet
light
and they tell the kestrel exactly where
to look for its prey
keen extrasensory vision keeps the
kestrel fed
thanks to sight in the ultraviolet
spectrum
360 degree vision makes life dangerous
for a bee
whenever a jumping spider is around
this acrobatic creature ignores the web
when it gets hungry
jumping spider is a hunter
with eight extra powerful eyes
[Music]
on quiet legs the spider maneuvers into
position
[Music]
and then it puts its amazing eyes to
work
[Music]
four eyes on the back of its head scan
for movement to its rear
[Music]
while in front four more eyes track the
prey
the largest eyes themselves don't move
but inside the eye the retinas can scan
back and forth
[Music]
with great distance vision for a
creature this size the jumping spider
stalks its prey
while the bee feeds the spider climbs
into place
eight eyes and eight legs ready to
pounce
the spider continues carefully into
position
it connects a silk tether to its perch
unaware the bee laps up nectar
the spider sizes up its jump
[Music]
calibrating an exact landing before
attack
a perfect hit
the usefulness of wrap-around vision
doesn't stop till the bee is dead
because while it struggles the spider
still keeps an eye on that stinger
and finally
success
one less bee in the garden
in the ocean
sharks are among the most streamlined
inefficient hunters on earth
and they've honed all their senses into
lethal weapons
sight
smell
taste
touch
and sound
but a shark not only sees and hears its
prey
it can feel it
first many sharks have a sensory organ
that runs the length of the shark's body
and fans out on its head and jaw
called the lateral line it's full of
nerves that pick up subtle vibrations
and pressure changes in the water
it is so finely tuned that when combined
with its other senses a shark can detect
prey from over a mile away
next pores in the shark's head called
ampullae of lorenzini are groups of
sensory cells that can detect weak
electrical charges such as the
heartbeats or muscle movements of
creatures hidden in sand
each ampulla is filled with a jelly-like
substance that reacts to changes in
pressure temperature or electrical
conductivity
these pores are so sensitive that if two
flashlight batteries were placed a
thousand miles apart and a single wire
were strung between them a shark could
detect the charge
when hunting for a meal sharks may call
upon all of their senses
the distant sound of splashing might
alert them to possible prey
or perhaps the scent of blood draws them
in
closer in their excellent eyesight may
come into play
vision and ampullae of lorenzini along
with smell and hearing all function in
unison to plot a deadly path
a bone-crushing artery-splitting bite
satisfies the shark's sense of taste
scorpions have a sixth sense too
which comes in handy for hunting at
night
if their venomous tails don't get you
their legs will
each footstep sounds like the t-rex in
jurassic park
[Music]
organs on the scorpion's legs sense the
shock waves
and if there is an insect moving within
three feet of it the scorpion will
detect its movements
[Music]
for its next trick a scorpion can do
something else few animals can do
[Music]
glow in ultraviolet light
[Music]
that's because of fluorescent chemicals
in its body
[Music]
why
nobody knows
[Music]
but one theory is to attract insects
that see in uv light
like a moth to a flame
this moth is lured toward the glow
[Music]
sensitive hairs on the scorpion's claws
detect the flap of the moth's swings
as the moth gets closer vibrations
intensify
[Music]
hypersensitive body parts give this
scorpion a powerful ground game
[Music]
but
underwater this ungainly creature has a
sixth sense that is hard to beat
australia's platypus
has the tail of a beaver
webbed feet
and a bill like a duck
but this is no ordinary bill
it is a supersensory organ laden with
thousands of cells responsive to the
electric fields generated by all living
things
so to hunt the platypus closes its eyes
its ears and its nose and lets its bill
do the work
called electrolocation it is thought the
waving back and forth motion we see here
helps the platypus to locate exactly
where electric pulses are coming from
the pulses are like neon signs
advertising fast food
and when one looks promising
the platypus digs away
all thanks to its sixth sense
but even six senses are no match for the
bizarre powers of mind control
beneath these breakers
in warm tropical seas
[Music]
this fascinating creature lives and
hunts
endowed with powers of hypnosis
to protect itself from predators a
cuttlefish can disguise itself at will
but when it's looking for a meal
it does something even more amazing
controlled by the animal's nervous
system
these moving bands of color captivate a
wary crab
special cells in the skin expand and
contract to produce a mesmerizing light
show
that lulls its prey into a deadly trance
[Music]
when it's close enough
it snatches its prey with two long
feeding tentacles
and hypnosis pays off
hypnosis doesn't just exist under
water some land animals have developed
their own techniques
these stoats can be found dashing around
the english countryside
chasing down one of their favorite foods
rabbits
[Music]
but when just chasing doesn't get the
job done
the creature turns to an unexpected
superpower
[Music]
the stoat
on the hunt
will go nuts
this manic behavior gets the rabbit's
attention
who could ignore a stode on steroids
[Music]
spinning
jumping and twisting
the stove inches closer and closer
but the rabbit remains transfixed
until it's too late
as effective as the hypnosis of the
stoat in the cuttlefish may be
there are creatures like these parasites
whose hypnosis crosses the line into
something even more bizarre
mind control
beneath this peaceful landscape
a snail has eaten parasites
they've turned it
into a zombie
these spectacular bizarre bulging
eyeballs are the snails tentacles
inside them parasitic worms have begun
an amazing feat of mind control
[Music]
these parasites have taken over the
snails tentacles
and its brain
it's all part of an ingenious plan to
extend the life of the parasite
and its offspring
the snail has become possessed
it is doomed now to follow the parasites
will and the parasite is on the move
looking for another host
next the parasite needs a bird
hypnotized the snails march into the
sunshine
they climb from the shade to the tips of
exposed branches above
[Music]
the snails tentacles
in gorge now by their possessors have
grown to resemble a maggot
and a maggot is the favorite food of the
birds above
in an instant
the bird attacks
and the parasite triumphs
the parasitic worm happily multiplies in
the bird's stomach
its final trick is to complete the cycle
but it will have little trouble
as the snails below graze on bird
droppings
filled with a new batch of mind
controlling parasites
once they're eaten
the hypnosis of the snails will continue
and the life cycle of the parasite will
roll on
many animals will run from their
predators
but just because an animal can run
doesn't mean it can hide
from a predator with super hearing
the great gray owl lives in the arctic
where even in summer its meal can be
buried under inches of snow
to hunt it locates its favorite prey
mice and other small rodents
by listening for movement far below
the feathers surrounding each eye
function like a dish antenna
directing sound to the ears
[Music]
each ear receives sound at a slightly
different volume and angle
which allows the owl to pinpoint where
the sound comes from
[Music]
it focuses on unsuspecting prey
as much as two feet beneath the snow
and sets off
on the attack
[Applause]
they continue to listen throughout the
approach
[Applause]
[Applause]
to finish the job
owls have become masters of the dive
bomb
super hearing will ensure this owl a
full stomach tonight
tomorrow the listening will continue for
the owl
and for another winged predator far away
lurking in the darkness
and also gifted with super-powered
hearing
for the vampire bat super powered ears
are also its eyes
and they work in astonishing ways
[Music]
at dusk when the day ends for many
creatures
the vampire bats day begins
they leave their roost in search of food
to navigate they rely on a special trick
of hearing called echolocation
to understand what's around them bats
produce a high-pitched noise
the noise registers beyond the range of
human hearing
but it travels outward from the bat's
mouth hits the objects around it and
bounces back
these sounds then tell the bat what's
around it
fast enough to let it fly through
jungles without hitting trees
and fast enough to find prey
like the peccary
this bat sizes up its prey and decides
to wait for the 40 pound beast to go to
sleep
[Music]
[Music]
once the peccaries turn in the bat
cozies up to a likely spot where the
feast can begin
[Music]
along with super powered ears these
vampires have heat sensors in their
noses
this guides them to where warm blood
flows just beneath the victim's skin
with her scalpel sharp teeth she makes
an incision to draw blood
they only get a taste before the peccary
wakes up
[Music]
for bats smaller prey is usually more
manageable
fishing bats also use echolocation to
direct them
sense of sound can guide them so well
that they can hear fish surfacing in a
pond
they use that sound plus echolocation to
time their dive to the exact moment a
fish rises close enough to the surface
in an impressive display of timing and
winged agility the bat skims the water
picking off fish with its long legs and
claws
using echolocation and otherworldly
hearing
a bat like this one can catch and
consume up to 30 fish in a single night
while some predators rely on
extraordinary skills to overcome their
prey
others rely on extraordinary strength
the natural world is filled with super
muscle-bound beasts
and strength
can clearly be a superpower
but pound for pound
the power brokers in the animal world
are not the big beasts
but the small ones
this rhinoceros beetle can lift 100
times its body weight the equivalent of
a man walking a mile with a car on his
head
[Laughter]
strength which comes in handy when it
thrashes horns with rival beetles
but the muhammad ali of the animal
kingdom is this little guy
[Music]
a mantis shrimp might not be a heavy
weight
but ounce for ounce
it can throw some of the fastest and
most powerful punches in nature
the mantis shrimp spots its prey with
hexnocular vision
two eyes that have three focal points
each
and so many light-sensitive cells they
can see in the ultraviolet and infrared
with dinner in its crosshairs the mantis
prepares to strike
[Music]
running for cover under a discarded
glass is useless
the club of a mantis shrimp can easily
break quarter inch glass
and the shell of a crab
[Music]
the mantis stores energy in its arm
it works like a spring-loaded mechanism
when the energy is released
the mantis smashes its prey with the
force of a 22-caliber bullet
now that is a super powered punch
[Music]
the cheetah is the world record holder
for sprinting speed on land
[Music]
gazelles are fast too
but not fast enough
the chase lasts less than a minute
[Music]
any longer and the cheetah's own body
temperature could kill her
super speed underwater
looks rather different
the sailfish advances
they've been clocked at leaping out of
the water at speeds of up to 68 miles an
hour
like cheetahs their super speed is
limited to quick bursts of velocity
giving the sailfish a plausible claim to
the title of fastest predator in the
ocean
but despite the sailfish and the cheetah
each endowed with super speed on land
and in the water
the fastest animal on the planet rules
the air
the true super-powered king of speed is
about to clobber one of these pigeons
a peregrine falcon may chase a pigeon in
one of two ways
the first method is the flat out chase
sometimes it works
but pigeons are fast too
and when jostling back and forth with a
peregrine in this mode
prey will occasionally slip away
when this happens
the peregrine can recalibrate
and switch to method number two
it's called the rapid stoop
the dive bomb
the attack begins slowly then gradually
picks up speed
its wings tucked in
the falcon is approaching 200 miles per
hour
it is now the fastest animal on the
planet
against this super powered speed the
pigeon is defenseless
it's tough to hide from an attack like
that
but even the fastest animal on earth
can't match a speed-driven superpower in
the jungles of costa rica
speed is everything for the basilisk
lizard
when you prey on winged insects you need
to be quick
because your prey moves fast
really fast
so when the basilisk is in a hurry
it displays one of the most spectacular
capabilities in nature
a true superpower
this flat-footed reptile is so fast
and so light
that it can run across the surface of
the water
at speeds as much as five feet per
second
[Music]
but speed alone doesn't make this
superpower possible
long toes on their rear feet
along with fringes of skin that unfurl
to meet the water
create little air pockets under the
lizard's feet and the air pockets give
the lizard lift
a true superpower in nature
in the struggle to survive a few lucky
creatures have extra special gifts
to be the strongest
the fastest
the cleverest
to get inside the mind of their prey
to feel them
or to see them
in ways that others can't
these are the blessings that keep a
creature
or a family
or a species alive
those lucky few with the rare advantage
of superpowers
[Music]
[Music]
you